450 watt männlichkeit ja video zu
sorgen auch bei geld hört sich ja es hat
also bei geld auf jeden fall also daran
sind ja schon viele dann zerbrochen und
du machst gar nicht so viel wie ich und
du bist genau das gleiche oder du christ
mehr hallo ihr lieben heute habe ich
wieder einen gast bei micky muss endlich
wieder und es ist niemand geringeres als
set von der gruppe aktiv mit herzlich
willkommen hallo hallo an alle leute da
draußen an die chemie und tier ich sehe
ich auch mein fleiß ist ja wie finde ich
einen sehr süßen
bei uns rechnen die schnittchen
das ist doch so hat die nummer dazu dem
blatt schnittchen cool ich freu mich
richtig dass du da bist ja da kommt
falls ihr es noch nicht kennen da gehört
zu gamer gruppe bi suite genau heute
macht er jetzt auch mit anni viel mehr
als mit gaming konnte ja wir kochen
backen so weniger meistens eher so
kochen noch quizshows und gaming
streaming also das ganze herunter klare
gewinner und 1 programm genauso wenn
jemand haltung braucht man sollte auch
uns dafür pro 7 20.15 man guckt einfach
so kann ich schon so lange kein
fernsehen ich auch nicht mal seit zehn
jahren quasi wenn dieser
nicht so auf youtube das war's ja ich
habe mir gedacht also ich stell dir auf
jeden fall fragen dann sehr gerne aber
ich kann da alles stellen quasi
schmerzfrei da gibt es eigentlich nicht
viel perfekt und wir würden parallel
einen kuchen backen ich hole mal kurz
mein handy hingegen backen ist
leidenschaft waren ja das habe ich ja
auch ihm war hundertprozentig geklappt
bei mir
zeigt euch mal das oder blenden smile
ich zeig dir das auch mal selber das
vorhaben und zwar habe ich ist es nun
foto was ich auf instagram gesehen haben
und das ist einfach wie so eine art
anime weiß ich nicht komme ich mit
kuchen ein bisschen hier wieder arm
kann man da noch so eine kontur einbau
nicht
das machen alle mal passiert aber auch
sehr lecker aus meine mama hat immer
seine sonderrolle gemacht aber dann
halte ich ihn grün und mia fancy aber
das ist sehr lecker
immer auch mit rein also ich hab wohl
kommen denn inspirieren lassen von
diesem bild und ich würde sagen weil du
ja gerade da will ich habe ja auch
kannst du dir den tag am piano guck mal
hier
450 watt
jakob mahl doch da geht doch was er hat
ja power der power aber man merkt auch
der ist der ist gut tun ist also und
uraltes bringen also hat man nicht den
geist aufgegeben und das auch qualität
weil sie ja sagen dass merck so langsam
der macht nicht mehr lange mit
vielleicht bringe ich ihnen ja kaputt
jetzt ja wenn wenn dann jetzt
ja da kommt man dann in die haftpflicht
die zeit
ok also
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt noch ich habe zucker
eingegeben und den weg und ich hab noch
wasser dazu gegeben und jetzt ist die
masse richtig schön dick und dann wenn
ich jetzt einfach noch die trockenen
zutaten hinzufügen ihr findet übrigens
alle ganz genau wenn an der
milchbar
[Gelächter]
wegrationalisiert haben soll was ganz
einfach machen ich habe jetzt gerade
weil das ja wir hatten auch mit auch
mancher ein teelöffel vom mehl weg und
ersetzt das jetzt durch macho das ist
diesmal so ein rezept ich probiere so
aus aber diesmal machen wir beide jetzt
einfach wird wir probieren was ist denn
matcha das ist ein japanischer t in
pulverform schmeckt so ein bisschen geld
bei ihr kennst ich kenne auch aus japan
ja gibt es nicht auch diese matcha
bällchen oder so oft wechseln zu lassen
hier heißt es okay okay was wir schon
mal japan nein ich würde so gerne dann
kann der cola ja wir waren nämlich auch
wir hatten quasi den flug gebucht und
dann genau camcorder werten damals im
mai fliegen soll und im april vacono
megabit zu den anderen war alles weiß es
nicht wir haben zum glück noch das geld
zurückbekommt von fluten das war auch
noch sagen kann ja überhaupt ja das von
einer nicht aber sonst war alles aber ja
es soll immer noch zu nah kommt der tag
ich kann das verstehen dass man aber du
bist ja so primär du bist heute bis zum
zocken richtig ja schon so ein bisschen
gamer und ihm als kind schon oder doch
ein gesprochen dann weißt du bist ja ich
bin quasi gestartet mit meine eltern
hatten so ein c64 so eine ganz alte
konsole sondern alter rechner quasi wo
du wo du nur den stick hattest und zwei
knöpfe und dann immer so spiele so
libysche spiele oder er wurde einfach
die ganze zeit hin und her und dann zwei
tasten drücken muss damit haben wir
gestalten
schwarz-weiß-fernseher dann hat jemand
schon mal in schwarz weiß fernseher
gesehen sollte kein bistum will dann
hoffen wir mal ja irgendwie erster
fernseher den namen wir dann als kinder
überreicht bekommt aber war sehr cool
und da war dann so der erste kontakt und
dann ja auch durch freunde und so ist es
dann hängen übrigen haben wir mal
zusammen gespielt so lars gemacht so
plan ist jetzt für die zeit danach
so ja ja
wlan ist damals noch busse noch nicht
das internet gab hat man sich mit den
computern zusammengetroffen im keller
eingeschlossen ja jetzt wohl zu machen
wieder deinen harry lieber dickel und
dann hat man die zusammengesteckt quasi
alles zusammen spielen kann und dann hat
man gegeneinander live vor ort gespielt
heutzutage geht das ja also das internet
ja aber früher musste man noch physisch
zum anderen jahren und heutzutage gibt
es ist natürlich alles viel einfacher
und so aber war auch cool arbeiten als
ihre pizza bestellen sondern richtig
jungs abend gemacht so das war es was
die jungs hat dem mädchen am clara party
vielleicht ja im dvds gekauft und die
jungs haben weil sie haben rechner dann
dahin gesetzt und gesagt das habe ich so
viele jacoba also noch
locker gespielt
würdest du mit
28 29 30 aber schon vorher sehen 30
neben 34 ist alles doch jedes dieses
jahr 43 ja bist du oder ich glaube ich
müsste mir eigentlich nur den bart weg
machen sich wieder aus wie zwei
eingeschränkten die meistens auch jünger
aus dass man mit schwindel sich
mitarbeiter oder ja was ist wirklich
krass soll irgendwann so mitte zwanzig
dachte ich mir so war irgendwie älter
aussehen wäre schon cool an und wir
haben 34 aus und sieht immer noch aus
wie 16-jähriger bubi da hat dann
gehalten und jetzt wo du älter bist
denkst dann so aussehen der pflege auch
mal ganz kühl aber so alte mörder noch
nicht wann bist du denn zur gruppe peet
mitgekommen ab könnte ja schon vorher
wir können uns von den außer aus dem aus
der schule quasi aus der fünften klasse
haben wir das sind auch die mit denen
wir laden gemacht haben früher und so
nach grad nach dem gymnasium nach dem
abi hat sich das dann so in die welt
verteilt und haben wir aber weiterhin
noch über das internet dann zusammen
gespielt abends und irgendwann hat einer
gesagt hey lass das mal aufnehmen und
hochladen und wie wir zusammen zocken
und so gegeneinander betteln das kann
man gut an und und das hat man heute
auch 2011 haben wir angefangen dann
einer von uns dann damit angefangen dann
kam immer mehr dazu ja immer mehr videos
dann teilweise 20 videos am tag
hochgeladen am tag das war eine ganz
wilde zeit aber auch die studienzeit
darin vielleicht ein bisschen
aber er war krass 20 videos am teils
schon pensum wir haben ich wollte wie
viel haben wir jetzt
23.000 videos auf dem kanal war
wirklich sehr freuen aber ich war doch
alles erst angefangen wie wie glauben
sie dass sie überhaupt youtube
angefangen ich einer der ersten waren
schon sehr früh dabei also später hatte
da irgendwie bock drauf hat das gesehen
fand das interessant und wollen das auch
mal ausprobieren und dann sind wir dabei
geblieben was bei den leuten an dem wir
gut ankam und im wiener coole
interessante sache war da auch zu
interagieren und mit der community dann
und die sich aufzubauen ist dabei die
dann wahrscheinlich auch so gestartet
wieso ein selbstläufer ja also hat
einfach bock gemacht weil wir haben
genau das gemacht was wir immer gemacht
haben wir haben uns zusammengesetzt und
dann einfach nur hochgeladen oder
anderen haben uns dann einfach dabei
zugegangen ist nicht so schön das gar
nicht dass du eure leidenschaft avanti
betrieben oder soll irgendwann würde er
damit selbstständig na ja irgendwann da
an der
kasse schon danke gedauert und damit den
die firma 215 haben wir glaube ich die
firma gegründet ich habe noch weiter
studiert und war erst noch arbeiten und
maschinenbau studiert und habe das
zweieinhalb jahre auch noch selber dann
ausgeführt als als ingenieurin und habe
dann irgendwann gesagt so die
doppelbelastung schaffst du nicht mehr
du kannst dich 45 stunden woche haben
auf der arbeit und dann abends auch noch
ganze zeit aufnehmen das war dann doch
ein bisschen viel für einmal ist halt so
professionell dann bei uns wurde konnte
man nicht einfach sagen auch heute mal
nicht oder so dann bin ich dann auch mit
vollzeit reingegangen die anderen jungs
waren schon voll zeit vorher da und so
hat jeder dann sein studium dann wie
gemacht und dann kam vollzeit in die
tiefe reichendes kraft also wirklich vom
gelernten ingenieur das ist okay doch
nix dann ein hauptpunkt denn gelernt das
war auch echt schwierig das war also die
frau dazu gehören ja das war glaube ich
gar nicht das war gar nicht das ding
nähe weil beides ja cool ist hat dann
eher gefreut dass ich immer wieder zeit
haben wollten aber also doppelarbeiten
gehen also vor zeit ist dann halt auch
trick gewesen war war die richtige
entscheidung auch wenn ich manchmal so
ein bisschen schon in meinem alten job
mit trauer das war ich cool du kannst
jederzeit wieder einsteigen würde das
war was er sie besuchen habe das erste
video was wir auch geladen haben ist eve
online sondern ist ein weltraum spiel
aber so minecraft haben wir sehr viel
gespielte terraria das sind so die
ersten großen projekte bei uns gewesen
die wir zusammen gespielt haben oder als
battlefield und auch gespielt call of
duty ganz viel alles so auch so bekannte
bekannte videospiele sein wo dann auch
dann die zuschauerschaft zeit mal dass
google und auch er stößt ja aber auch ja
genau dass wir waren dann auch immer
einen der ersten kanäle die sachen dazu
hochgeladen haben haben das um
mitternacht hingesetzt und die videos
aufgenommen und direkt hochgeladen damit
sie die ersten sind oder aber was wir
halt auch mit 20 videos pro tag haben
wir damals auch die startseite sehr
unter kontrolle gehabt also damals für
youtube noch nicht so krass bestimmend
war so wie es heute ist konnten wir dann
doch wenn wir auch sehr präsent auf der
startseite mit soviel videos haben wir
uns dann eben wieder da durchgeboxt
haben obwohl ja heftig wegen guten
riecher gehabt auch mit den 20 videos am
tag dienstag ist es ja nicht mehr so
vielleicht auch die werte der zuschauer
es ist schon sehr algorithmus getrieben
selbst wenn man gut ist wie du raus das
ist ja auch manchmal eine zuschauer
sehen wollt es geht dann mal unter ein
abo ja aber total oder gar nicht erst
gar nicht mal so hell seit wann hat ein
neues video herausgebracht und das muss
ich jetzt erstmal halten kann muss man
kämpfen
noch anders ja das war super easy
einfach das gesehen was er wollte
23.000
gucken 23
sind 560
ja da ist auch sehr viel quatsch bayer
aber dass der versuch kurze videos dabei
oder
eigentlich nicht international
25.000 videos
25.000 videos 2000 mehr als die meisten
videos sind so 20 minuten lang glaube da
kannst du schon also wenn ihr jetzt
anfängst hast du vielleicht bist du dein
leben
gehabt er hat zu tun ja ich würde sagen
du kannst es mal so kurz wie notwendig
unter rühren das ist eine masse wird und
ich muss schon mal papier genau
vorsichtig schon vorsichtig damit das
nicht so kaputt geht der flug
tours wurde zunächst warten können
ein bisschen was bei meiner mama von
meiner mama noch hin geblieben hat
nämlich auch sehr gerne ja bei mir ist
das irgendwie nicht so durchgeschlagen
genau so der grüne daumen der ist auch
von meiner mama nicht auf mich
übergesprungen pflanzen funktionieren
soll und die serben haben ja die stirn
ich schon aber wir versuchen es jetzt
nochmal jetzt mit eigenem garten kann
sich zumindest ein paar pflanzen mal
hinterher und gebaut
neben ja auch schon online wenn das
video hier könnt ihr gerne mal von denen
dann sieht man nämlich auch mal so ein
bisschen was von der prima also geld
ausserhalb der gruppe
von bugs
wie das das einfärbt also das hat er gut
klappt ja ich hab zum lebensmittelfarbe
raus gut weil ich dachte okay das auge
isst mit ich wird dann auch vielleicht
nochmal nach aber wir lassen das macht
das machen dann können wir nicht direkt
packen
[Musik]
so wir haben jetzt das ganze umgefüllt
in den backen und dann in den ofen
geschoben also die ausgeben es geht
langsam aufwärts überhaupt benutzen sie
zwischen zeitung wir machen dann schon
mal die creme
egal wie langsam starten und landen ist
überflüssig was also soll nach dem
vorschlag soll da kommen gleich nochmal
hinter extrakt dazu müssen
was ist denn dein lieblingsrezept zum
backen oder zum leitet auch zum backen
zum essen oder zum selbermachen sind
muss ich das auch noch mal die vielen
so sehr macht der normalen kuchen
schokostückchen und holzkirchen drin ok
also
angeles und der schwarzwälder kirsch
wäre jetzt dass mein favorit ja aber
nicht meint also wo du so einen weißen
die mama kuchen hast und dann einfach
mit so schokoraspeln drinnen unserem
praktischen drin lass dich unterwegs ja
und das kenne ich ja noch selber machen
das habe ich auch einmal schon verpackt
weil da irgendwie die menge beim apfel
nicht so ganz gepasst hat hat er eben
die deutlich matschiger als er sein
sollte aber nicht so dass das kriege ich
auch noch aber der schwarzwälder kirsch
selber machen ja schon fast die
anleitung jahr mit sehr viel zeit und
vielleicht ein bisschen übung aber nicht
so aus dem stand und heute ist ja vorhin
gesagt er kann man landpartie pizza
gemacht haben ja und dann haben wir auch
dinner für zwei ist ja auch was ist so
ein snack wurde sagt du zockst nebenbei
greifst du immer was ist so etwas immer
essen kann unser niveau chips chips
habe ich in letzter zeit häufiger gehabt
oder nachos was ist variiert immer so
ein bisschen aber ich es so sicher ja
wobei ich heute gerade einwerfen aber
ich es auch gerne wild durcheinander
also in die chips gummibärchen
schokolade und dann immer eins davon
nacheinander
king pervers ist aber eigentlich ganz
gehalten
manche also ich darf nur chips essen
also nur dann was in die einzige ist
heute abend und wenn du dann schokolade
dazwischen ist
aber jeder jeder sowie am markt
[Musik]
also jetzt haben wir hier die creme
fertig gemacht genauer ein quark
betragen wichtig für die steuern masse
und klasse
innerlich so wie jetzt ich hab ja auf
instagram nach auch nach so community
fragen und sie fragt jemand das hat mich
ein bisschen gewundert warum ein mit
soße sind nicht alle mit so super
bekannte rezept er kommt noch eine soße
ich kenne ich nicht bayer mit
buttermilch soße als jetzt aber auch
nicht so wirklich lecker kann ja du hast
ja das kochbuch auch ja vielleicht auch
nicht der eyecatcher und das rezept was
dich direkt gefesselt hat schaschlik und
schaschlik vom tc ist megageil vier mega
geil das kann ich 100 prozent empfehlen
aber bei mir bayern ist so große risse
familienrezept und das ist schon echt
schön angerichtet von von dem koch der
das buch wäre der für das buch gekocht
hat wir haben das auch selber mal nach
gekocht oder sieht eigentlich aus wieder
brauchen ist wenn du es richtig machst
zutaten ist überschaubar wir sind
eigentlich nur eier butter milch und
sogar so und noch ein bisschen butter
und das ist familie rezept und ich muss
selber zu geben also schon sehr
feierlich ja es ist so kindheit bin ich
dass das rieche das esse dann ja
manchmal sind das wirklich die einfachen
rezepte wie einfach sich so gut
schmecken aber mit butter ich glaub mir
das mal aus selbst habe denn dann macht
einmal mehr zucker rein
optisch doch sogar sehr viel zucker das
ist eigentlich eher süß ich werde es
ausprobieren
genau vielleicht schon bei uns mal ins
video rein wo wir das nachkochen und da
gebe ich noch ein paar hinweise wie man
es okay wie es dann auch richtig
aussieht denn nach familie ist nicht
wirklich ausbauen und das buch ihr habt
ihr das kommen wir gern noch mal zeigen
weil ich es richtig cool ihr habt das
hier zu fünft gemacht es gibt aber auch
aktuellen hausse verkaufen das gibt es
fünften auflage wahrscheinlich aber mehr
sind unsere lieblingsrezepte aus unseren
koch formaten drin bewerten die ja immer
dann am ende der der folge damit die
üblichen sachen eingepackt und von jedem
dann noch so private rezepte dir
empfehlen kann oder familien sowie bei
mir familienrezept oder so viele rezepte
von meiner mama ich sehr empfehlen kann
auch seine herrencreme megageil ja liebe
ich auch ihr habt nicht so süß und
herzhaft haben wir hier die das ist nach
dem nachdem nach der platzierung ist das
aufgebaut dann hier platz eins ist
krustenbraten erst geworden ich glaube
ich habe noch nie so einen richtigen
krustenbraten gegessen aber nicht also
wenn ihr wenn die schwarze dann so
klopft und so richtig knusprig ist
hammer rehragout auch ganz lecker sein
nicht so diese genau ausgefallen ist ja
echt nicht so dieses standard was man so
kennen ja immer im blick zum körper wir
haben aber bei mcdonald's hatte nur um
die eigenen apps mitbürger
da hat einer bei uns aus der community
du kannst ja bei mcdonald's gab es mal
so aktionen dass die bürger selber
kreieren kannst und die meisten votes
bekommt der wird dann wirklich auch mal
früh im monat oder so gab es denn dann
und das hat halt einen arzt aus der
community eingereicht wir haben darauf
hingewiesen haben hat der hat gewonnen
weil er auch geschmacklich wirklich gut
war dann haben die in der die besten
zehn die am meisten bewertungen gekriegt
haben kam dann vor sondern jury bei
mcdonald's und die haben gesagt schon
solide schon geil das sind daher auch
dann so privaten so dass man jetzt nicht
in youtuber die das eigene reich
irgendein
der wird dann auch bei mcdonald's der
war auch mit dem gesicht auf der
verpackung ja habe ich auch noch zu
hause stehen die verpackung megacool das
war echt geile aktion ja es ist schon da
war seine leckere soße drauf auf dem
burger die gibt es nicht mehr
ich habe mir du kannst nachkochen
da schon sehr nah dran und also werde
ich ein gefühl in die info box
verzichten genauso wie natürlich auch
die kanäle weil es kasse ist doch auch
wenn ich nicht ich nehme keine gegnerin
aber trotzdem abends ich mache mal auf
dem fernseher geschaltet allem das meer
vor unterhalten das sind projektions
dabei ist ein komplettes dabei gut bei
den gaming musik sagt da guck dir haben
sondern vielleicht mehrmals ist wirklich
so für jeden was dabei und das kann ich
so cool war ich danke schön so ich mache
weiter hier mit dem weil der boden ist
auch schon fällig also es ist ein ganz
normales sauberes geschirr tuch mit
puderzucker bestäubt
damit man später nämlich auch gut wieder
abbekommt es ist jetzt mal rahmen
geboten mit puderzucker bestäuben damit
dass hierfür außen anders geht das
einfach nicht so antrag zu sicherheit
dann kann auch das teilnehmer war zwar
nicht weil mir würde den geschmack fast
perfekt guck mal stellt sich
ja das geht immer gut was mir daran
klebt ja das ist schon sehr groß
geworden dessen
was kann man in der post mit peter und
so kann man das machen ja stimmen
dann sehen wir zwar aus wie er jetzt
aber das grün da das ist richtig noch
selbst machen wir gleich noch mal
einfach thema obendrüber wunderschönen
nach ihm kommt drüber und dann darf das
können wir machen mal die creme drauf
das ist so stabil wir haben andere
sachen schon gekocht vorhin die nicht so
stabil geworden was wir nicht gemacht
haben ist seht ihr dann natürlich auf
dem kanal diesen chats mit hallo und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
pcs kocht heute mit unserem gastro ja
wir werden heute etwas freestyle kochen
wir machen heute ja was machen wir
eigentlich eine art bürger mit maxis
alles was wir haben uns dieses foto und
das geht es darum nach zu machen
wir wirklich sehr geordnet professionell
nicht ohne ende hier im gegensatz zum
video kann man nachrichten dort drüber
und dann dass ich mal kurz abkühlen dann
geht es weiter
[Musik]
der biss gebunden ist abgekühlt
ich muss jetzt mal verwechselt as safe
niemals auf dem etikett ja sie farbe
trifft sich ganz aber muss ja auch nicht
wir haben einfach was eigenes google
sieht jetzt aus wie eine grüne wiese das
ist nun können diese genau hat etwa
gleich teuer genau so schön sein
optimismus ist
immer immer gerne und ja auch so von der
dicke her gar nicht so auf dem bild das
ist er hier hdr und ich würde sagen ich
du kannst dir die winkel paletten er ja
und dann kannst du das so gleichmäßig
wie möglich verteilen mauer
sprach den platzherren häuschen gebaut
und wird sich jetzt gut damit aus ja wir
haben noch nicht so eher weniger steine
das ist wir haben nicht gekleckert gab
es nicht im angebot
heutzutage nimmt man ja was man was man
bekommen mache ich das überhaupt richtig
also ich hätte jetzt zu vom gefühl her
gesagt lasst euch vorne ein bisschen was
frei weil wie man es auf rollt dann
drückt man ja stimmt das drückt dann
sollen in den randen genau guck mal du
bist du bist die kinder die fachfrau
dass das klingt irgendwie logisch ja
aber das sieht gut aus und jagt er jetzt
auch einen süßen so und julia und es
kann doch die frage bisher hat nicht
auch mal interessiert schaffst du
irgendwie dadurch dass sie jetzt papa
wird auch weniger jetzt für die gruppe
oder bist du immer noch ein pensum ist
nach wie vor am anfang war mein pensum
gleich jetzt langsam habe ich habe ich
gemerkt ich möchte mich ein bisschen
mehr zurücknehmen weil jetzt auch in das
alter kommt am anfang sind sind babys ja
noch sehr
jahre gleich die ligen heidrun liegen
halt um schlafen viel brauchen halt die
windel und so interaktions mäßig ist da
noch nicht so viel aber jetzt kommt er
voll in die phase er läuft jetzt
erkundet die welt kann auch schon so ein
bisschen sagen was er will und was nicht
und ist voller energie und das macht so
viel spaß für jeden tag lernt er
irgendwas neues entwickelt sich weiter
und hat total also das ist voll geil
und jetzt habe ich gemerkt nimm dich mal
zurück und
genießt da ist weil in einem jahr ist
das alles im die alltag und dann ist das
wieder was anderes und dann kannst du
dann kann es immer noch arbeiten dass er
sich bei uns wir sind fünf leute da kann
man halt einer wenn er wenn er mal was
hat sich ein bisschen mehr zurücknehmen
und dann springen die anderen so ein
bisschen neuer das ist
ja genau kann man so gut kompensiert und
eher klein ist ein land halbjahr will
schon was die zeit rennt davon ist der
ist ja schon groß er ist 18 und zieht
aus
[Musik]
mit denen noch nicht 18 ist das alles
noch durch leben dass das werden wir
nicht so schnell weil im moment ja am
anfang habe ich gedacht ich bin kann
also ich wusste schon dass ich das ich
gerne kinder haben möchte und so aber so
emotional habe ich gedacht oh papa sein
ja ob deshalb ab aber das sind dass mich
das emotional auch so folgt und mit
nimmt hätte ich gar nicht gedacht ihrer
kinder sind schon machen auch mit einem
mann was komplett anderes irgendwie also
emotional habe ich glaube ich auch noch
nicht irgendwie so empfunden wie nachdem
ich papa geworden bestimmt ein ganz
neues gefühl viel in die vier emotional
für mich persönlich sonst tangiert mich
doch nicht so sehr aber bei dem kleinen
schon nimmt nimmt an dass er mit
beziehungsweise erfreut einfach viel
mehr wenn der lacht das ist einfach das
ist wirklich das schönste so ja gerade
die welt ihren ja wirklich so wichtig
auch eingeschätzt also dass du nicht
sagst da war hier auf krampf mein
content machen sondern man nimmt sich
dann wirklich die zeit und man ja ist
dann wirklich für den kleinen darf die
familie kann mich noch frage rein wer
kocht besser das ist das ist eine
schwierige frage ich glaube die richtige
antwort ist sie koch besser ja anfangen
weil sie auch nicht nur zuguckt und sie
wird sich das video auf jeden fall
ich würde sagen wir haben beide unsere
stärkeren und schwächeren rezepte sie
hatten sehr viele starke deutsche
antwort
welche eine richtige antwort
sie kocht wirklich sie kann mehr gute
sachen aber es gibt auch sachen die sie
nicht gut kann und da ehrgeizig sie
glauben auch ganz gut und ich kenne auch
guten grossmann und so ach so ja
dann muss man reicht so gut wie rossmann
bands ist ein guter bürger man ja auch
wichtig noch wichtiger immer schönen
notfall kontakt speichern
so wie man jetzt mal den rhein aber auf
dem bild gesehen zum beispiel zweck von
dem gedanken dass es so aus sie dürfen
damit aber nein wir machen sogar eigene
denken ja ein bisschen habe ich für die
deko aufbewahren ich hab's gesehen ganz
einfach so rum quasi und da wollen wir
so eine polonaise oder was genau nur in
einer linie bleiben weil es uns ein
bisschen mehr schrieb schon hilft ihm
sein oder h ich glaube wir brauchen aber
noch mehr erst wenn wir das gleich quasi
aufgerollt und dann kann man auch schon
dekorieren für
muss sagen beim backen überrascht mich
immer wieder wie einfach das eigentlich
sein kann ich habe das immer so
kompliziert wie im kopf so aufwendige
dinge sind so eine schwarzwälder
kirschtorte ist total aufwendig oder du
hast du machst dir ein teig und
schneidet den dann irgendwie mit einem
seil mehrere schichten und so für mich
über super kompliziert und geht
eigentlich immer china aber sowas ist
also ich sehe nicht ein wenn man lassen
so drin ist und anfängt das machen dann
ist dann sogar ist gar nicht so an so
anstrengen auch von den zutaten hast du
das auch schau war wenn ich das auch
machen möchtest du dass ich das auch
rolle ja gerne
ich also da muss ich jetzt ja mehr oder
weniger du hast doch schon mit dem tuch
so genommen hätte das tuch jetzt schon
gar nicht genommen aber läufst du kannst
tun ich glaube das ist besser als
reichstes ein mit meinen fingern aber
dann machen wir das so
das klappt aber
das ist nicht schlimm
wären bestimmt gleich eine schöne
oberseite
das sieht gut aus
ein bisschen krems darüber dass die
seite auch sehr gut ja das kann man
abschreiben
na ja ich wollte sagen dass das könnte
jetzt in der mitte durchbrechen das ist
es wie beim döner dann doch drinnen dass
ich hoffe mal schnell war so wir können
uns auch zu hilfe wieso paletten oder so
nehmen oder meinst wie viel ist das
klingt auch guck mal das kann eigentlich
gar nicht schief gehen ja perfekt die
schöne seite nach oben ja grün ist
anders aber wie gesagt das ist unsere
eigene interpretation von diesem foto
wichtig ist eigentlich dann mus lecker
sein ja es ist viel wichtiger als erstes
vollkommen recht er kann noch eine frage
geht rein nicht der ist ja einfach mal
glaubst du dass pete heute ein schwarzes
t shirt trägt ja ich glaube der peter
trägt heute auf jeden fall ein schwarzes
t-shirt ja also wenn ich ein schwarzes
t-shirt trage dann eher auf vier stunden
oder man ja viel abwechslung ja
das war glaube ich einer bei uns aus der
community haben habe ich auch weil wir
haben bei uns in den videos haben wir
einen trägt peter heute ein schwarzes
t-shirt counter weil wir haben ja sehr
viele videos und peter trägt wirklich an
98 prozent der tagen trägt ein schwarzes
t-shirt kommission zuständig
ist peter ist es mit peter spitzer und
dort war so sein gamertag peter smits
opensuite soll sich damals in einem
videospiel genannt und er hat er seinen
kanal dann auch genannt wir haben am
anfang überlegt weil wir eine gruppe
sind ob wir das anders und zu benennen
nach der gruppe aber eigentlich wollen
wir dann so
dass ein trick sagen ja weiß dass ihr
seid eine gruppe und man denkt nicht
sofort an diese eine person sagen
heute ist eure sprache kommt wenn fünf
diese ganze arbeit und es ist das ganze
geschäft oder es ist dann wirklich so
dass heute ein zwei geschäftsführer die
natürlich denn die geschäftsführer
arbeiten aufnehmen übernehmen aber sonst
haben wir uns eigentlich das meist so
arbeitstechnisch schon auf na
ja genau auch so eine den was wir so
einen aufträgen und zusätzlichen
arbeiten haben das kriegen wir
eigentlich immer so hin dann macht ja
mal ein bisschen mehr dann macht er
wieder mal sicher wäre schon mehrere
youtube ist ja ja die jungs mir zusteht
renntag getrennt aber er hat es durch
das problem wir haben einen auf der
strecke gelassen hardy wir waren mal
sechs aber der wollte einfach etwas
anderes hat sich hat sich für sich was
anderes in der zukunft gesehen und hat
dann gesagt ja du also entweder geht ihr
mit dass dass ich alleine was weiter
machen kann oder und dann haben wir
gesagt wir können wenn nicht wir können
nicht sagen okay jetzt kann jeder sein
eigenes ding machen sondern wir müssen
als gruppe zusammen bleiben wenn du dein
eigenes ding machen möchtest kannst du
es gerne machen china folgt ihr dabei
aber wir können nicht sagen wenn mit dem
eines sagen okay du kannst du dich
machen und in der gruppe was
gleichzeitig machen als zerbricht das
irgendwann und das wollte ich wollte
eigentlich immer zusammenbleiben und zu
sagen okay aktivkreis machen so lang ist
im guten getrennt ja
genau muss musst du auch bei wenn du so
eine firma also zusammen für das merkt
ihr auch ihr müsst ihr auch irgendwie
zusammenhalt geht das ganz schnell
abstellen manche sorgen auch bei geld
hört sich ja es hat also bei geld auf
jeden fall also daran sind ja schon
viele dann zerbrochen gerade wo der eine
neidisch geworden ist auf den anderen ja
das ist natürlich dann auch schwierig
oder der eine dem anderen sagt du machst
gar nicht so viel wie ich und du hast
genau das gleiche oder du gehst mir aber
wenn es doch untereinander also das ist
solche streitereien man man hat mal
haben sie auch mal streit das wetter
zwar
weiter aber also seid ihr kommt ihr alle
wirklich so gut aufeinander klar und die
seite kennt euch ja auch schon ja das
ist wirklich ein vorteil wenn du dich so
lange kennst dann gibt es eigentlich gar
nicht so dann kennst du die marken von
dem anderen und muss dann nicht wie
pippi werden du weißt was dich erwartet
du weißt er hat vielleicht mal dann auch
in schlechten tag und so sieht das aus
wenn den schlechten tag hat so muss
darauf reagieren damit dass ich es
kariert das klappt ja ich glaube das ist
dieses zusammenspiel dass alle dieses
ihr kennt euch seit jugendtagen ihnen
ihr versteht euch gut ihr habt das aus
leidenschaft gemacht dass dieses
zusammenspiel das alles glaube ich
echter erfolg ja dass wenn wir jetzt
nicht zehn jahre da wo wir so sind das
zehn jahre ist auch nicht mehr lange
zeit der gruppe
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sind jetzt fertig richtig gut gereinigt
auch also hielt er hat so schön hier
picasso aus boulder sich ok lucky
picasso
recht gut auch dran klingt und blieben
ja bin ich auch jetzt überlegt man die
sahne schwarz wärme aber dann wird er
grau als schwarze lebensmittelfarbe dazu
gibt's war kate in schwarz grün hat echt
gut funktioniert und jetzt will ich
gespannt muss auch schmecken da wo wir
teilen uns mal ein stück können wir
nicht machen wir haben wir auch mal sein
eigentlich stieg ja du bist wenn du mal
gucken verspeisen möchtest musst du
einfach anja bin ich auf jeden fall zu
haben immer einen ampera
speichern ich möchte mich zitronig oder
wie schon ich glaube das liegt am platz
neun jahre älter skandal note aber
schmecken den matsch heraus nicht auch
nicht also wirklich um 0,9 dafür war es
doch halt einfach zu wenig matschiner
war es trotzdem sehr lecker brawn dass
ich vom stil marihuana schön sommerlich
endet nicht so medienwirksam sind manga
dieser kommt
ja erst da so alles drauf und gespannt
pezely raffi
und natur fairytale dann erst mal hier
ich bin doch zwang von dragonball und
der hass darum anderen combo und winter
und noch
verlängern weil überwiegt auf deinem
hammer darunter und auch den drang war
selber naja aber das soll ich gute sie
zu währungen zu mehreren ja hätte ich
die nicht gefunden hätte ich auch keine
netto also ich bin jetzt nicht so der
typ deshalb heuer und das eine aber die
habe ich gefunden und die hat genauso
den stil gehabt die den nicht haben
wollte so wie ich mir das vorgestellt
haben hat dann gepasst das hätte ich mir
nie so gemacht das ist ein mann dann
endlich diese künstlerische ader hat ja
oder nicht nicht so dein stil
widerspiegelt und dann hast du was auf
dem arm was das auftreten
sollte hier
ja ich lebe ich beim portier beweist
ja ich locker gewonnen ja bin ich auch
also wir genießen das stück und
wahrscheinlich dass du da warst ja
vielen dank für die einladung vielleicht
noch mal ja also schreibt gerne mal in
die kommentare auch wie ihr so die folge
fanden hat und wenn wir irgendwie noch
eine zweite folge sind möchte schreibt
unten rein was du noch was zu sagen
letzte wort hat die mütter alles gute
ich bin eine heimliche zuschauer und ich
wünsche euch viel spaß
[Musik]